the movie begins on a flight flying from
Chongqing China to lasa in Tibet Captain
Liu and his co-pilot Kai expected to
make a smooth Landing in about an hour
they are extra careful because the
aircraft is flying at a higher altitude
which causes periodic turbulence
everything is running smoothly until
suddenly the pilots hear a crack and see
that the windshield has been slightly
damaged Liu remains calm and contacts
Air Traffic Control informing them of
their emergency before the operator can
confirm what he heard the crack gets
bigger in less than a second the entire
windshield breaks
foreign
setting off the air pressure in the
cockpit copilot Kai is launched out
through the window and Leo leaps out of
his seat to catch him the scene abruptly
cuts to a few hours earlier Leo is in
the shower holding his breath for as
long as he can he does this every day
and can go more than five minutes
without breathing does this exercise
have a purpose or is it just a sexy game
he plays today is Lee's daughter's
birthday hence he promises to return
home for the party at the end of the day
after he sets off for work we can see
the cabin crew driving to the airport
everyone arrives in a good mood and
starts pre-flight preparations Liu is
flying alongside a fairly new pilot Kai
we are also introduced to the third
pilot Wang they all check their vitals
before meeting the rest of the crew and
discussing the weather conditions and
duration of the flight outside the
passengers wait while the airport staff
does a last minute mechanical check the
flight attendants inspect the emergency
lights oxygen masks number of meals and
such before reporting to the Head
stewardess be non in about 15 minutes
everything is prepared and the
passengers are let onto the craft one of
the flight attendants is bullied by a
rude passenger when she asks him to turn
his phone off he is an internet
celebrity who thinks he's entitled to do
anything because he is above other
passengers on board I hope that guy dies
later be non helps the poor flight
attendant and deals with the passenger
professionally at last the plane takes
off smoothly making everyone believe it
will be a decent flight but little did
they know what is about to come next in
the first half of the flight the plane
experiences heavy turbulence the air
traffic control has already predicted
this considering the change in weather
hence Liu simply calls them and asks for
permission to fly at a higher altitude
where the clouds won't bother them the
passengers on the other hand are calmed
by the flight attendants who do their
job efficiently in some time the
turbulence ends and everyone is relieved
as Leah talks to Kai about his personal
life we find out that he used to be in
the Army before joining the commercial
airlines their conversation halts when
they hear a noise and see the windshield
is cracked slightly they know it is not
a good sign but remain calm and contact
the air traffic control immediately the
operator is about to suggest they go
lower but before they communicate the
windshield breaks completely launching
Kai outside Leo quickly holds him back
and tries to keep him inside the plane
however the pilots struggle Against the
Wind and pressure building in the
cockpit simultaneously the right engine
bursts and stops working unable to take
the load of the airplane now the lives
of 119 passengers and nine crew members
are in the hands of Liu since the doors
to the cockpit are closed the passengers
in the cabin crew outside do not feel
the effect of the pressure change they
experience heavy turbulence but do not
think much of it since it has happened
before everyone is asked to be seated
with their seat belts on while Wang and
binon try to get a hold of the pilots
inside the cockpit when they get no
reply from inside they finally register
that this is not just regular turbulence
in the cockpit Kai is mere seconds away
from being thrown outside the window Liu
pulls himself together and decides to
take control of the plane before trying
to save his co-pilot he jumps back to
his seat tries to contact the operator
again this is even more difficult
because they're flying over the mountain
and the plane can crash into one of them
at any time suddenly the airplane makes
an aggressive right turn Throwing all
the passengers to their side this is
when Panic starts to set in and they
start strapping themselves tightly the
flight attendant helps the kids and
older people on board risking their own
lives for the safety of the passengers
as Leo tries his best to control the
airplane the turbulence only gets worse
then he makes a harsh turn in hopes of
sucking Kai back into the plane the plan
works but it also causes the door to the
cockpit to open the air pressure inside
the entire plane changes as it jerks
backward forcefully a flight attendant
is thrown to the ceiling while she is
trying to help a passenger similarly
everyone else on board is also jerked
forward the oxygen masks drop and the
remaining hostesses help the passengers
wear them when the airplane stabilizes a
bit Wang moves forward trying to get
inside the cockpit to help the others
even the rude passenger from earlier
tries to push him forward when it comes
to his life both Lee you and Kai are
about to pass out when Wang finally
enters the cockpit even in such a
condition leave does his best to keep
the airplane in control holding his
breath as much as he can Wang makes the
captains wear oxygen masks which helps
them a bit and they are able to punch in
numbers to get the plane to a lower
altitude I wish my wang was this heroic
somewhere else in the air traffic
control office chaos ensues when they
see the plane descending at a
frightening rate the communication with
the pilots is also cut off which is a
clear hint that something has gone
terribly wrong they inform the other
offices to make room for the flight's
emergency landing several flights are
canceled all across East Asia because of
a chain reaction in addition firemen
paramedics and many other emergency
workers are sent to nearby airports to
prepare for a landing the control room
also sends three fighter jets in search
of the plane while the pilots flying
them try to contact Liu through their
respective radios the people on the
ground do everything they can to find to
the plane and ensure the safety of the
passengers and crew but in the end it
comes down to the pilots to save
everyone's lives the door to the cockpit
is now locked stabilizing the situation
on board the passengers are in a frenzy
but they remain seated as ordered by the
flight attendants benon comes forward to
confirm the positions of her team asking
them to press the call button on the
ceiling when their names are called
everyone responds to their name one
after another except for the last flight
attendant who had been slammed into the
ceiling earlier the others try to wake
her up repeatedly and are about to give
up when she suddenly raises her hand
affirming that she is still alive her
team's size with relief and watches her
pull herself together into a seat they
are proud of her for holding herself up
but the situation requires them to focus
on the matter at hand at the moment
benon then announces that they have lost
cabin pressure and requests everyone to
stay seated with their seat belts and
oxygen masks on meanwhile Wang removes
his mask to yell into the microphone
against the air hitting him through the
broken windshield his efforts do not go
to waste as people on the ground hear
about the depressurized cockpit the
operator reveals that the plane needs to
descend below 3000 meters to gain enough
oxygen but the mountains below them have
an average height of 4 500 meters this
means they have to cross the entire
Plateau without crashing into any
mountains in order to survive with only
one engine working and a depressurized
cockpit it is almost impossible to
achieve such a goal in the next hour the
news about the airplane makes it to the
internet friends and family of people on
board start panicking trying to find as
much information as they can the plane
should have landed by now so the people
coming to pick up their family members
start blaming the airport employees for
keeping them in the dark in the meantime
trouble adds up when a thick cloud
formation blocks the airplane from going
forward flying above the clouds is not
an option but flying directly into the
storm would be inviting death itself
this is when the passengers lose their
cool and start revolting a drunk man
gets up from his seat yelling at a
crying child to stop when the flight
attendants ask him to calm down he
pushes her aside demanding to know what
is going on he also Rams a food trolley
into another flight attendant hurting
her Gravely benon comes to the scene
urging him to trust their Captain the
only person who can save them at this
point the other passengers join her
making the drunk man get back to his
seat and shut the hell up meanwhile in
the cockpit Wang tries to keep the
pilots warm while they fly the plane in
circles trying to avoid the storm on the
ground Liu's wife is preparing for her
daughter's birthday party she is shocked
upon seeing the news about the airplane
but she is positive that her husband
will bring the plane back she also
assures her daughter that Lou will be
back before she knows it and they will
celebrate her birthday together at the
same time Liu's mind goes hazy and he
imagines his daughter cutting a birthday
cake the vision gets more Vivid as he
slowly loses Consciousness posing a
great threat to the entire plane Wang
comes behind the captain and shakes him
to wake him up properly if the situation
continues everyone on board will fall
unconscious the plane will continue
moving on autopilot and eventually crash
when it runs out of fuel after making
several circles Lou finally sees what he
was way 4 a tiny pathway is cleared
between the clouds that he can fly the
plane through people from the control
room praise His quick thinking and watch
as the plane flies into the dark clouds
the turbulence gets worse and Luggage
starts falling from the compartments
overhead the control room watches the
flight nervously until it suddenly goes
off the radar everything goes silent as
they assume that it crashed but their
prayers work and we see the passengers
are still alive somewhere between the
clouds the captain pulls a lever
propelling the plane forward with all of
his might several minutes of silence
later chatter continues in the control
room when the plane comes back on the
radar but although it got out of the
storm it is completely tilted and
nowhere near stabilized the safety of
119 passengers repeats in Liu's mind
again and again preventing him from
passing out at any minute at last the
airplane passes the clouds and the
turbulence ends after seeing death up
close the passengers start confessing
their darkest secrets to each other a
husband tells his wife that he lied to
her about his job but she forgives him
instantly he also tells her he's a furry
and she's confused many other people
make last videos for their loved ones
hoping to say goodbye to them in the
following scene the plane finally
reaches the altitude where there is
enough oxygen and the pilots take off
their masks for a better view the
connection to the control room is
re-established and they are told where
to land every other flight around the
airport is halted and landed immediately
inside the aircraft passengers and the
crew get ready for an emergency landing
while outside the reporters get ready to
capture The Descent seconds before they
land the passengers are fueled with a
will to live they all chant encouraging
words and Brace themselves for the
impact the plane finally touches down
but keeps moving towards the end of the
runway everyone is worried that it will
crash but at the last second all three
Pilots pull the lever collectively
making it come to a halt when the
suspense ends The Operators jump in
celebration but the passengers are so
overwhelmed that they break into tears
Liu talks to the speaker and apologizes
to everyone for the inconvenience in
turn the passengers collectively give
him a thumbs up thanking him for saving
their lives after everyone gets off the
airplane an officer from the management
Bureau comes in to investigate the
malfunction it turns out that the
cockpit had not been pressurized
properly because the aircraft was old
upon seeing the condition it is in the
officer calls Lou an incredible pilot
and thanks him for his work Lou gives
his family a call telling them he will
be home soon he is interrupted though
because of a noise outside which turns
out to be the passengers shouting to
thank him Captain Leo and a few other
cabin crew members bow to the passengers
to express their gratitude the movie
ends as the passengers from Sichuan
Airlines meet their family and friends
thankful for the miracle that just
happened to them finally we are shown
pictures of the actual cabin crew who
experienced this incident in May of 2018
pictures of the real Sichuan Airlines
flight 8633 after the incident are also
shown subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching